some things to talk about because this
all hit on friday and you know people
enjoy their weekend and sometimes it
takes a little time for all of this to
digest how about cam newton
back with the patriots three days before
he would have been eligible to agree to
terms with any other team the patriots
and cam work out a deal
and and this is another one of those
where
the lie gets all the way around the nfl
media world before the truth has a
chance to even begin to get out of the
cage that it's being kept in there was
wrought one report that cam newton's
gonna make close to 14 million no he's
not it's a base package of three and a
half million roster bonuses take it to
five million he's got to play in every
game or be on the roster for every game
to get to five then he's got a nine
million dollar superstar incentive
package to get to 14. so another great
deal for the patriots because if this
guy makes 14
great investment it will mean they have
won the super bowl chris so uh your
first reaction when you saw that cam is
staying put with the patriots uh i i
wasn't shocked i mean i think both you
and i thought that there was still a
possibility that that could happen you
know i think that's the first thing one
of us a little surprised with some of
the reaction you know
especially you know up in the new
england area
you know
like oh man we're bringing cam back and
i know it didn't look like great but i
also think there's like a a a faction of
people that are
not really being realistic about what
they saw last year too that would be my
first year it was a 7-9 football team
that had what
two three heartbreaking losses i mean
they were this close to being ten and
ten and six
so you're not that far off even with cam
newton and the struggles and covid and
him not getting a training camp but
doing all those things i mean those are
real issues so again i expect cam newton
to be better this year i'm not shocked
by that you know so then here's my other
thing mike too i guess this is probably
the other thing that popped into my head
because we know teams want to formulate
themselves right this time of the year i
don't think it's any coincidence we saw
drew brees retire right the day before
free agency teams want to start having a
plan wait who's our quarterback who are
we gonna get around him now that we know
that guy is our quarterback and fitting
that all together but the other aspect
is something i've been saying on my
podcast and on radio stuff the last few
weeks is
i thought oh cam newton got signed and
went well there goes jimmy g back to new
england that was the last thing i
thought of you know
and and because i really thought there
might be a chance the jets still zach
wilson they trade sam darnold and then
of course 49ers call the patriots and i
think that's dead now
well
that's interesting you say that because
we had tom curran on pftpm he covers the
patriots for nbc sports boston he thinks
there's still a chance that garoppolo
ends up in new england that because of
the magnitude of the contract given to
cam newton again right absolute minimum
base value of three and a half
five million if he's on the roster for
all 16 games on a per game basis that's
not much in the grand scheme of things
they have the cap space they could still
bring in jimmy g now cam newton may not
be happy about that because you
negotiate this incentive package under
the assumption you're going to be the
starter but you got to win the job yeah
and maybe maybe it'll be jimmy garoppolo
not jared stidham who ends up competing
with cam newton so i i i i tend to side
with you on this right but when current
says uh jimmy g i hear you play i i'll
at least i'll at least keep my eyes on
what may happen i think that the
patriots weren't going to wait to see
what happened with jimmy g exactly they
risked losing cam newton while they wait
but now they got the bird in the hand
they can wait to see if they can get the
garoppolo in the bush well i i agree
like the first the with the last thing
you said there totally right you're
right like they couldn't wait you got at
some point we got to figure out
something here who's going to be our guy
just my experience playing from josh
mcdaniels and denver to working up there
a little bit and that stuff i mean
they're a team that believes in kind of
like hey there's our guy we're going to
formulate around him and do that i i'm
also with you in the fact that when tom
curran speaks i listen about new england
always so i'm certainly not discounting
that i'm just saying as a guy who's
followed the patriots for a long long
time i would be shocked if jimmy g ended
up there i just don't
i really would you know one
now that you have cam
on your football team they're going to
be able to play if it does get to this
conversation they're going to be able to
low ball okay for lack of a better
phrase the 49ers because they're like
well we got a quarterback we're not that
desperate so that's going to lower his
trade value and i i can't imagine the
49ers loving that uh but i think the
other other thing is too kind of going
back to the formulating of the teams
i i i just can't imagine new england and
bill belichick and josh mcdaniels liking
the
cam newton jimmy garoppolo both in our
locker room you know somewhat dividing
the team one guy has a little different
offense we run and this guy has that i i
just don't see that happening i think
you're gonna see cam newton jared
stidham
and then a good chance new england
drafts a quarterback somewhere in the
first three rounds something like that
typical new england and that's the way
they go that would be my me calling my
shot here you know as an early march
the the other thing too about garoppolo
and the 49ers in his situation there
with that 25 million compensation
package now none of it becomes
guaranteed at any point they have to
carry that cap number though you know
last week i was surprised that trent
brown
didn't just dig in with the raiders get
cut and sign with the patriots as a free
agent then the patriots don't have to
give up any trade value brown calls a
shot but the raiders my understanding
was we're planning to squat on brown and
keep brown around so getting it done now
that was part of the reason for the
patriots to do the deal would allow them
to turn around and trade marcus cannon
right et cetera et cetera right but uh
with garoppolo i think
the patriots could be a little more
hard ballish
with it because they they could say we
don't want 25 we're not taking the guy
at 24. yeah that's right we're not
taking we're no we will not pay him 25
million right and he can say i'm not
taking a pay cut so then the question
becomes how long do the 49ers want to
carry him on the roster with a 25
million dollar salary cap and cash
number plus another one and change on
top it's a big chunk yeah on a guy if
you've trade for sam darnold or
otherwise sign someone or require
someone that that you that you want to
make your starter so they can continue
to wait now that's the key with cam news
definitely
the patriots can fold their arms and
wait to see if garoppolo gets cut
because i still think that's the end
game i still think he gets cut
if and when the 49ers find someone else
that they think is dollar for dollar
better doesn't have to be better yeah
just dollar for dollar better than the
25 million they're due to pay garoppolo
the the other alternative is as we and
we suggested this when they started
sniffing around teddy bridgewater maybe
they try to squeeze jimmy g to take less
than 25 that could be the end result as
well maybe they maybe that will be you
know you we we talked about trent
williams you know the last hour and
maybe them wanting to resign him of
course we know they want to resign him i
mean trent williams he was there with
the shanahan family when they were part
of the washington football team he's a
special left tackle we saw last year the
guy missed a whole year of football he
came back and he was still the best left
tackle in football you know he's he's a
hall of fame left tackle in trenton
williams so maybe that's the squeeze
they put on them i just i
i at least don't envision you know
they're gonna have to find somebody else
that i would think is at least equal to
or better than jimmy g to where they're
gonna cut him or do that and that to me
right now as i still don't know you know
i know we heard the jimmy the teddy
bridgewater rumors last week in that
conversation i was surprised to hear
that i really was but i think your point
in where
you know i think bridgewater is less of
a player than jimmy garoppolo
but he was what eight million dollars
less against the cap this year as
compared to garoppolo too so that could
be a big aspect of this but i just don't
imagine the 49ers cutting jimmy g loose
until they have somebody they look at
and go wait we think he could start for
our football team and we can win games
and that's what we'll keep our eye out
for here as we go forward but i i think
the jimmy jeted new england thing i just
would be shocked if that happened i
really would i just knowing new england
and evaluating them over the years
i would think they go with cam and go a
different route
another thing they could do with
garoppolo in san francisco is just say
hey garoppolo you and your agent you're
authorized to go see what any other team
would pay you and report back to us what
another team would pay you if you were
cut because you need to realize 25
million in getting it done this year we
got to do something else now as to cam
newton yeah
second year in the system covered 19
issues behind him i really do think that
messed him up physically and maybe a
little brain fog last year although he
denied that we still don't know the full
extent to which the condition affects
people
reason to think that maybe last year is
the floor
and it can go up from what we saw in
2020. i think so i do you know not only
the covid and taking them out of rhythm
there listen you're just getting used to
an offense and you're you're getting
used to your own place and all of a
sudden hey wait you're sick and you got
to go sit in a room for two weeks and
then oh wait you know you get back into
the swing of things think about again i
know the throwing wasn't off the charts
there's things we gotta fix
we also saw games early in the year
where we went the throwing was off the
charts good the seahawks game week two
the sunday night football game it was
one laser and bomb after another i mean
i'd like to remind everybody at that
time everyone was going like well that
just proved it it was all belichick it
was all belichick at that time that's
what everybody was saying you know okay
well we we know that cam had issues he
definitely has to fix some mechanical
issues of how he throws there's issues
there all together that led to
inconsistency and balls where you just
go you're too good to be missing that
but you know i i've seen too much good
to just abandon ship on cam newton and i
think he can get those technical issues
worked out and to your question mike
like is it fair of course i think it's
fair i mean new england's got more cap
space than anybody i would be shocked if
they don't get out get out there and get
some really good free agents here maybe
not stars not this first wave but that
next group of guys and
he didn't get to take advantage
of what i call the greatest system in
football or it was greatest system i was
ever a part of certainly you know that's
the other thing when he starts to learn
all the things that this system has to
offer and they can put that on his plate
it's going to make that offense more
efficient too and i think that's where
they're excited probably to get them
going and get them in the building to
where they can get going here and start
you know wiring their robot
different schools of thought on whether
it was coincidental or deliberate but
the patriots with a ton of cap space are
in a position to bargain shop don't
expect to hear and look i'm i'm walking
right into the old testament exposed
tweet don't expect to hear the patriots
agreeing to terms with someone from
market value today they've done it twice
in 20 years at daley's thomas 07 stefan
gilmore what four or five years ago
they're gonna wait there's gonna be so
many bargains out there they can make
that team better they can add a bunch of
guys get some pass catchers tight end
you know maybe a kyle rudolph ends up in
new england once he sees what else is
out there i think the patriots wait and
wait and wait and start adding guys
spending that cap money wisely and
they're gonna have a better team around
cam newton than they had a year ago i
think that's going to be a factor as
well chris no agreed i think it's
definitely going to be it's one of the
better o lines that's out there
they just added trent brown like you
talked about a few minutes ago they can
they can dominate people
i mean we saw games last year where we
literally went
the patriots can't throw the football
you know they're gonna run the football
and they were still pulling guards and
doing things and smashing people's face
in and running at will on some of the
better teams in football so they're
special that way
and if they can get yes cam newton
more of the offense implemented to take
advantage of the schematics that of
course belichick and mcdaniels can offer
along with some talent and then we know
that defense has got some covet 19 opt
back ins and those type of things yes
i will not be shocked if we're sitting
here next december we're talking about
the patriots going back to the playoffs
i don't think that's a big you know a
huge obstacle for where that team sits
as we sit here right now midway through
march
they haven't drafted a quarterback
higher than the second round probably
since drew bledsoe in 1993
could you see them add to that depth
chart with a high pick and that becomes
a guy who gets groomed quietly behind
cam for a year or two well i think if
it's the right guy at that pick i i'd be
i just you know where they're picking at
15
gosh i don't know i don't envision it
there i i don't i really i don't
typically i want to say that they're
gonna look for somebody in that second
third round for a guy to go that way
there
uh but but at 15
you know of course we don't expect
trevor lawrence or zach wilson to be
there
you know is a mac jones maybe there
maybe
again i'll sit here and tell you the
kellen mon kid from texas i think is
every texas a m is every is every bit
worth that pick
and he could be a guy that would be
maybe made for hey let's sit here for a
year and you can learn a little bit and
go from there
but i i'm not gonna put anything out of
the realm of possibilities this year
they're they're playing with money
and they got a ton of it
and they got a lot of assets to play
with in the draft and i think you might
see them make some aggressive moves you
might maybe this is the year mike maybe
this is something we see this year
four first-round quarterback picks in
patriots franchise history drew bledsoe
tony eason jim plunkett and
some other guy that i had up here
someone named concannon in 1964. so not
a lot of first round picks in franchise
history used on the quarterback position
tom brady if you hadn't heard was picked
number 199 21 years ago and
one last point on cam newton
he's 2-0 all the time against tom brady
right so and they play this year
they play this year the buccaneers at
the patriots this year so he gets a
chance to go to 3-0
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports